okay
um all right uh so I mean for those of
you who said you're single what I mean
in today's day and age what does being
single really mean you know
so you said you're single correct yeah
I'm single I'm unmarried and
um non-exclusive
you know not really even a situationship
I mean I have someone I love very dearly
who lives in the UK
and don't really know what the future
looks like but when we see each other we
are very much like a relationship
Dynamic but outside of that I don't ask
his business wait so hold on are you in
a relationship with this guy I love this
person and I think like I mean like
what's a relationship like I'm in a
relationship with my best friend you
know like these are all relationships
it's just um am I free to date yes
do I have someone that I love that I
consider a potential future like
exclusive partner yes
is he seeing other women
I think so a bit are you seeing other
guys I was but not anymore yeah I'm not
really interested in like actually
dating do you want to have kids one day
I do I think I do
I I mean I wouldn't even he wouldn't I
wouldn't be talking to him or about him
like this if I didn't see the potential
for that that's really wise yeah well
you know we wise up eventually
hopefully or we don't
uh but I mean he lives in the UK and you
guys don't really have any doesn't sound
like you have an established
understanding really in terms of the
boundaries of your relationship no and
that's kind of like there's a beauty to
that I mean there are times when I when
I like subscribe to the social norms
where I'm like oh [__] like do I need to
have him committed to me and like you
know all these things and I'm like do I
even want him to be committed to me am I
ready to be committed to him
um I don't know I don't know like I
can't necessarily answer this question
so uh right now so I'm you know taking
it Taking time like really developing
the connection like you know
establishing what the values are really
establishing whether this is like a
future father of my kids and if he is
um then like you know taking it to the
next level I think ultimately I do long
for an exclusively monogamous
relationship but I don't know I've
always been really Progressive really
open-minded about like ownership and
possession
okay but you said you were single but
you're currently in love with a man in
the UK so I said I said I love him very
dearly
is there a difference between loving
someone dearly and being you're not in
love with him and you know I think I
mean God I'm in love with so many
aspects of him I haven't really I'm
pretty guarded and this person lives
like long distance right so the nature
of like the the interactions that we
have is like are like like short-lived
couple you know three weeks a month at a
time in these gorgeous exotic places and
it's not necessarily like you know a
great way I mean I don't know I think
I've always been a skeptic about like
well how do you know you're in love you
know is he a wealthy guy
um I'm not dating him because of his
wealth but is he he's I mean it's all
relative but I wouldn't Define him as
like a um like a rich guy
like financially Rich okay
um
it's really very very highly educated
like he's like upper class
or something I met him in a really cool
place
um he's he's you know like not
necessarily no
can some whose glasses are those uh
just no glasses do you want them on put
them somewhere not on the table please
that works okay
um so you're in love with him you see
him how frequently I love him so much I
love him very dearly he's one of my
greatest like one of the I've loved him
more than I mean we our relationship is
so stemmed and like founded in
friendship
you want more with him
I think so I think so I mean I think so
have you had that conversation with him
we did it early on in the relationship
what does he say
um I mean early on we were pretty like
we met at a wedding and we were like
there was love in the air okay like a
really romantic setting and um and I was
really at first it was like it was like
a week-long wedding in Pakistan and we
like every night at the end of the night
we kept on gravitating toward each other
and we just had these really really
wonderful
um deep like conversations and I didn't
really see anything like I felt platonic
friendship but at the end of the week he
like came over and he put his like hand
on my leg while we were talking I was
like oh I was like oh he's like you guys
are singles
and exactly and I was like am I into
this and I was like I'm not necessarily
not into this but it was it took me by
surprise because the whole time I had my
eye on someone else at the wedding
because I was like
you know I was like yeah but um I ended
up really developing this connection I
even remember saying to someone there I
was like okay I don't know which guy it
is this is like Midway through the week
I was like with this guy the one I'm
talking about the connection has grown
with this other guy it's kind of faded
The more I've seen it was like
attraction and the more I see the less
attracted I am and my friend was like
well obviously it's the one with whom
the attraction and connection grows and
it's just continued to grow
um I have like a deep respect and
appreciation admiration for him how long
have you been dating dating him I guess
you could say right
um January 2021
okay so two and a half years about is it
you because it sounds like you're both
it seems from what you're saying it
sounds like you're both interested do
you think it's you or him that's kind of
pumping the brakes well okay here's what
it is he's come to the US and he's like
[__] that [__] he's like hell no he is
like no not gonna happen I haven't spent
enough time in the UK so I mentioned to
Pro who lives in London that uh that's
why I'm asking him like how do you like
it she's like no I'm like I am moving I
am yeah and I like the sun right and so
he's pretty like fixed he has an
established life in London do you think
if you want to see him like that you
guys would date if you like move to him
I think so if I was in London like yeah
we think we'd be together as he said
that
um
I haven't asked
but and you know and I don't know that
it would be fair to ask unless I moved
there and we spent time there like you
know like long you know longer you know
um period of time because everything's
been in Snippets for us about a month at
a time so you've been dating him for
since January of 2021 during that time
period have you been seeing any other
guys yeah oh yeah
the first year of that
um I was still just kind of like
carrying on with like like dating and I
was dating like I was dating like fully
dating like multiple like all right
dinner tonight dinner tomorrow you know
um now I'm not dating I'm not really
interested how frequently do you guys
talk like on a daily basis weekly or
several times a week okay
alternate like call once a week but like
a lot of texting
okay um well we'll maybe we'll come back
to that um
in your Twitter bio you state that I am
not for sale but my nudes are that's
that's that is yeah attention can you
say that one more time they're for sale
on only fans
that's a hell of a marketing tagline do
you like it no I appreciate it yeah do
you want to know why I put that up
recently is because I had an offer made
Dubai yeah yeah and I was really
bothered by it but to be honest with you
I was really bothered by it not for okay
not really I mean I don't judge there's
a lot of escoding that happens in these
industries as we all well know
um but it was it was the approach and it
was also
um it was also the fact that I'd heard
from a friend recently about a traumatic
experience and she's a high earning big
name porn star and she had a very
traumatic experience escorting and she
is in therapy for it and it just broke
my heart and yeah Nick open it up please
[Music]
okay really quick question on that I
suppose I can open this up to the entire
panel so
there's not like a price
whenever whenever I started whenever
like 10 mil you wouldn't oh
do you see a barcode I have to ask an
honest question can I ask you as someone
who like a little closer okay can I ask
you um as someone who just left porn why
are you offended that someone would ask
you that like because as someone who
went into I knew exactly the kind of
treatment I would get so anytime I got
asked those as I guess I could say
stupid questions I knew it came with the
price you know what I mean so I would
never be offended that someone saw me as
an object when I'm putting myself on
display as an object okay okay very
valid and um and I think that like I
think what offended me is honestly the
fact that I it was probably projection
because I considered it because I was a
good price and I was like you know so is
there a price so I think that's why I
was like wait a second you know it was
it put things in perspective but I was
offended because this guy was [__]
name dropping left and right all of
these actresses that he works with and
I'm like you know what I don't need to
know who you work with I'd appreciate it
and in fact if you'd show them Respect
by having some discretion so I was
offended by the whole experience but not
like the approach itself well okay look
so just open it up to the entire panel
um
and this is related to what you have in
your Twitter bio
do you have a price
like for me dude if someone offered me
10 mil I'm taking that [__] it's like a
house my house I'm taking it for sale
but so it comes up and it's like yo
[__] 500 million dollars you know
what I mean like it's not for sale but
you know it depends on the person too
somebody's really offering me 10 million
dollars to buy me it would really depend
on the person okay but I also hate the
fact that men think that they can like
own you that's why I like your Twitter
bio because like we're just talking like
six like sex one time
I mean in reality
porn is technically that
working working for PornHub is
technically that getting paid for sex is
technically
I don't understand why you would hate
like a man owning you if that's what
you're selling she didn't
I'm I think a picture of her or a video
of her yeah
I thought that was what you said here
let's just go around the table so you
get
one is there a price where you'd be like
I'll sell sex for that price
I mean I guess I'd love to say no but at
the end of the day if somebody came up
to me with 10 million dollars cash and
said have sex with me here's like I
don't know I don't know what I'm gonna
do absolutely not wouldn't do it 10 mil
no more I know my morals aren't
completely there like I do only fans but
like I don't think I could get myself to
say I let somebody buy me for a night
that's that's set for life money you
don't have no way you'll have to work
again but you have to look at yourself
in the mirror again
and that's more important to me to be
honest like I've always said since I
even when I started I started stripping
when I was like 18 years old I blew out
the birthday candles and was wrapping my
[__] around the pool but I did always
say like two customers I saw the view of
my body but not my body itself if you
can find a barcode
there you go I'm gonna find one word
okay uh I'm tired of working so hell
[__] yeah
and it's only one night too
come on now baby let's do it
let's go okay
um
for me I feel like for the sake of my
dignity and out of respect for whoever
tilt the mic down towards you just ten
like this yeah that's good I feel like
because of my dignity and my morals I
guess I couldn't see myself setting a
price to do something like that and as I
said like out of respect to the person I
potentially might get with for a future
I wouldn't want somebody to be able to
say oh yeah I paid for her for the night
I just I can't see myself 10 mil though
and I know like 10 million is a lot of
money but like at the end of the day
it's like money is out are you waiting
until marriage
oh we didn't even get into that but good
for you okay
um
yeah there is no amount of money
absolutely not 10 mil no what if the
husband gives the green light he would
absolutely not
husbands confirmer tonight
that is uh too precious of a gift I
think it's time to buy a woman's body
that's why it's like sure yeah uh Zoe
what about you no not anymore if you
asked me six months ago hell yeah but
not anymore I'm doing like better things
I wish he would have caught me six
months ago
numbers uh Pearl no I'm okay 10 mil nah
I mean I just I feel like if I was that
desperate for money I'd just go live in
my parents house you know okay all right
I have a low-key like a story that might
be a little entertaining for that like
what you just said so at the strip club
one time I actually did get offered 5K
which is low amount but it was only to
for him to watch me finger myself and I
turned that down and he had the 5K in
his hand
and I still said no so he wouldn't have
touched me at all can I make a point
though
it was different about that and doing
all
well they can they can own a picture or
a video of whatever I'm comfortable
putting on the internet but I I wouldn't
meet with someone for money that's the
difference like you can you can own the
photo of me the video of me getting
[__] by somebody I would consensually
[__] in my free time but definitely not
like my body my energy that's for me to
distribute as much as I want also as
little as I want to whoever I want but
have you ever sold a video of you doing
that for five thousand dollars a video
of me fingering myself yeah sort of for
a lot cheaper than that but that's kind
of like but the video but but that's
them that but that's like not in person
because if you say yes to one person
live photo a live video yeah
if you sh if you do that in the strip
club though that guy is gonna go out and
tell his buddies and then he is going to
other everybody else in the strip club
is gonna be like oh I don't disagree
that doing it and then I put you in
danger now you're making like thirty
thousands
no I don't know that puts you in danger
don't disagree with you that doing it
inside the street and that takes out of
another girl's pocket and that's just
not right what's up ruins it
audio is delayed
it's still wait what a lot of people are
saying it or as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible